[Music]
people getting killed for various
reasons that something that belongs in
the movies or in a crime story but now
feel sometimes like I'm living in one
this is part five of what happened to
Annie and use six part series from Sky
News story cast I'm Luna Dougal
previously in part four no evidence has
emerged to suggest there is anything
linking Annie's death with CIA activity
at Prestwick Airport however the family
and journalists marchello may go still
believe annie was murdered the the major
thing and was the massive bruising and
swelling to our tempo which made me
think immediately that she had been her
very hard on the side of the head with a
blunt instrument baseball bat or similar
unsought to part five of a nice story
the case for suicide before it starts a
quick word of warning this episode
contains descriptions of death and
images of Annie after death that a
mother GU you has given us permission to
reference
[Music]
it's now August 2019 in the West End of
Edinburgh we're standing outside Molly
fields stadium near where Annie used to
live at Linton Court Apartments as you
can vote the front door you thund left
and you had a boat a thousand yard war
can you be a butterfield the last time
we were here
caretaker Derek brown spoke
enthusiastically about Annie's life in
Edinburgh she's a lovely girl very
outgoing quite vivacious and she was
really trying to get a hold of English
and I think that's why she tried such a
lot she used to tell me about going to
rugby club as well she'd become my rugby
fanatic she never mentioned depression
or any of that type of thing she's very
bubbly of course Annie was not only a
girl with an interest in rugby but a
sailor
[Music]
sniffing it and since we started making
the series Fanny's family have given us
another one of her songs Saturday night
recorded just months before she moved to
Edinburgh
[Music]
today now
but this image of a confident performer
was just one site Avani
in 2005 bill fell was the president of
Mari field Warren deters rugby club
before he only met Annie once in the
summer of 2005 when the club had Akili
but she stood out Ashley turned up to
one of these sessions and the Cauchy
turn of newborn mainly these kind of
events people would come as a couple or
as a group
if you ever beat Achilles you know as
people turn up mob-handed to want to do
hail and dancing of course cottage
country dancing they come out the squad
and the core she was in a row and she
sat on the loo and I spoke briefly it
was so I advertised so I had come along
to see her Wars and then she did come up
to the bar and spoke to me in one of our
band mates was of course the ng turned
out the following week when one of our
buses was going away to second 15-game
just to go and support the team
she was sure she was keen on rugby and
really that's the only contact the VRC
or anybody in the club I'm aware of had
Willa
Annie had different sides to her
personality like all of us but when he
consider she moved country on her own
well it's not that unusual to hear about
her socializing alone however bill
suggests that images like these were
taken as proof that Annie was becoming
withdrawn and that ultimately she would
self-harm and die by suicide he was
lashing the police she told me that
she'd cut it off I heard he had been cut
off no when I saw shed longer here Jimmy
have cut off here a month later it's a
timber thing whatever but her mother was
under the impression that it could've
been just prior to her death or if she
was under some
stress that she had to say did we have
some people self had him cut heel off
there's some way of relieving stress I
don't know these all the things that the
police house we know that when the
police interviewed Annie's friends in
Edinburgh some of them said she'd been
depressed we've tried to reach out to
these friends but for reasons we can't
explain
none have gotten back for us this was
surprising because they almost certainly
have important information regarding
Annie could it be possible that they too
have been scared off by the CIA rumors
that have come to surround Annie's death
or was she indeed depressed enough to
cut off her own here just like the
police told her best friend Maria she's
told me we're in this prayer
people cut their hair off and I said
well I don't think Annie would ever cut
her head off 14 years on Maria believes
the only thing that can solve the puzzle
of her best friend Annie's death is her
body her body will tell that's my main
focus and that's my that's what's what
is dreaming me a head so nine months
after we first met we went back to her
home office pathologist dr. Stewart
Hamilton of course the hair was an issue
no armed with both the Scottish and
Swedish autopsy reports he looked again
at the cases most troubling questions
starting with Annie's missing here what
we know from the autopsy report is that
plucked and cut hair were taken for
examination which was brought to the
attention of the police and Scotland by
the London embalmer we can also see in
the global networks document that they
have trimmed four to five centimetres of
hair when they were trying to assist
with making honey as presentable as
possible they note that the hair is
falling out during washing and combing
that's not uncommon when somebody starts
to decompose the hair roots become weak
and it will come out very easily
the London embalming company Global
funeral network's assistance claimed
Annie's body had not been properly
stored after she died
this is something that would have
increased the rate of decomposition
according to pathologist dr. Hamilton if
a body is in a fridge and kept cool then
decomposition will be slowed down if
it's left at to warmer temperature it
will be accelerated so we've got all
sorts of factors and forces and thoughts
all crashing together here
Annie's mother GU you an undertaker goon
had always believed the missing here and
scratches on Annie's knees were brought
about by some kind of struggle there
doesn't seem to be any particular
evidence of bruising bruising would
suggest that hair had been forcibly
removed at life and you get a bit of
bleeding from that I think the most
likely explanation is it is probably a
mixture of deliberate recovery of hair
for evidence and removal of hair during
a cleaning process but just like the
decomposition an alternative explanation
for this scratching was to emerge on a
return visit to preswick Beach when we
set out to understand how the
authorities might have arrived at their
conclusion of suicide
but how far they actually went we don't
know but back to the beach and the last
time we were here we missed something
because it had been high tide I mean I
was brought here before 50 the point by
Maryborough Road stood here in August
with a marine expert professor Stuart
Cunningham and above the wind and the
waves you can just about Heda making a
connection between the rocks on the
south end of the beach and injuries
matching some of those suffered by enemy
professor Cunningham says he's not
surprised to hear Annie's body had been
scraped a bit because the conditions on
the weekend she died would almost
certainly have brought her into contact
with these rocks on the beach yeah based
on what I understand the prevailing
conditions of the time of tide and wind
and currents I think the likelihood is
that age would probably have just moved
her backwards and forwards within this
vicinity and when you add to that how a
drowned body reacts in the sea this
explanation for the scratch marks on her
knees sounds convincing though we should
remind you that Annie's knees had not
been exposed when she was phone dressed
in dark jeans pathologist dr. Hamilton
one of the things that again people who
are used to dealing with bodies from the
sea are aware of is that a body will
float facedown so with the back on the
surface and the limbs dangling if you're
in relatively shallow water what's going
to happen your knees your knuckles are
going to come into contact with the sand
the gravel the stones at the bottom of
the sea so they will scrape across them
you will get a degree of injury in those
areas
but if Annie had indeed entered the
water waiting these jeans a pair of
white trainers and a red top along with
her jacket and bag then how was it that
the tide never scattered all these items
down the beach instead depositing them
close together marina expert Stuart
Cunningham I mean my expectation would
be because the wind was very late and we
would see almost no effect that items
are being moved around by the tides are
unlikely to have dispersed very far
apart they could have stayed quite close
together need other processes that
eddying emotions and so on to move
things apart and they take quite a long
time to start separating objects and
having used tidal data to explain why
Annie along with her jacket and bag
ended up close together on the beach we
wondered if it could be used to solve
the mystery of where Annie
entered the water Annie's body was found
because an area just down to the left
beyond the both they're called assault
cottages some things that might
potentially bring into play new
witnesses or new information I think
there's a whole number of unknowns
because we don't actually know when
Annie entered the water so that means
that we don't know if she was exposed to
one apt 8 1 apt 8 one flood tide if she
was exposed to only one of those she may
have been displaced several hundred
meters but not that far not out of this
general area
I would imagine now this general area
our marine expert Stuart Cunningham is
referring to it's actually the same area
of beach where the witnesses Andrew and
Doug saw the indistinct figure by the
waterline this would reinforce the
position of the Crown Office that it was
indeed Annie
stood looking out to sea that Saturday
in December
the to autopsy reports concluded that
Annie drowned but if she drowned by
suicide here in preswick Bay how was it
that no salt water our guy or diatoms
were found in her bone marrow sample why
the diatoms are not present in the
analysis it may be on the most extreme
theory though she did drown in brackish
water that was placed into the sea a
pathologist cannot exclude that the
other is that the analysis simply did
not identify them but why not just test
the long sample because they do have a
long some yeah it may well be that you
know diatom testing is expensive and
unfortunately this is the world that we
live in the more specialists to work the
more it costs and what about the DNA
sample on Annie's hands the one that
somehow survived being in seawater long
enough for a nice skin to wrinkle but
not for her body to take on a blue turd
effect pathologists dr. Hamilton again
on the simplest reading of this all that
it tells the observer is that a female
DNA has been deposited on on his hands
that could be shaking hands with
somebody it could be something more
sinister we don't know we're exactly on
our knees hands this DNA was found but
if you remember we only learned about
this DNA sample after the Swedish police
detective hands Melander visited
Scotland it would later emerge that the
police were unable to find a match with
respect to identification you can only
compare DNA to any database that you
have but if the person is not on a
criminal database
you have nothing to compare that sample
to you can draw conclusions about the
DNA but not then get a match with
somebody who exists then the police
would only have been able to make a
match if the DNA belonged to someone
whose details they previously had on
records and most databases of DNA in
this country and in Scotland either
people who have committed a crime or
people who are on what's called the
exclusion database so people who have a
good reason to potentially leave their
day and air to crime scene for example a
police officer it could also be the case
that the DNA never washed off because it
was never in the sea it could well have
belonged to someone tasked with
recovering Annie's body very simply that
means if someone enters a crime scene
they will take something of that crime
scene with them and they will leave
something of themselves there that can
actually be extended now particularly in
the era of DNA that if you interact with
another person you will leave something
of yourself on them and they will leave
something of themselves on you all that
that tells you that those two people
have Interactive's not how they've
interacted for us this attaches even
greater significance to the hard
evidence that was recovered like the
autopsy photos no one can access so I do
think that Annie was probably just a
very unlucky victim of someone intending
arroba but freelance journalist Marshall
omegle says the photo showed to him by
the family left him convinced Annie was
brutally assaulted and murdered because
of the blue to the head of God no doubt
was struck and then the case for suicide
this is the last thing we have to go on
so looking at the photograph
it's an old photograph it's not of the
best quality the family have given their
consent for pathologist dr. Hamilton to
view that image what I can see is I can
see some areas of discoloration to the
face particularly towards the right hand
side below the ear from the point of
view of the pathologist this looks more
like post-mortem change it looks like
trenches of decomposition rather than
true bruising that has occurred in life
from what I have seen and from what I
have read these marks are not described
the first post-mortem examination in the
further examination from Gothenburg the
translation that I've seen says that
they can indicate that they occurred
after death so I am not convinced that
there are bruises there that are of
significance I think the balance comes
down on these being postmortem phenomena
simply the result of the natural changes
of the body after somebody dies I would
never say that I could exclude that
Annie had been hit on the head and
dumped in water pathologists are
naturally cautious people it would be
foolish and irresponsible to say it can
be excluded but that is only a
conclusion that could be drawn when
there is a totality of evidence to bring
it up and a scenario is produced it's
worth reminding you that all dr.
Hamilton has to go on is to autopsy
reports and one greenie photo of Annie's
face we are without the kind of evidence
that might offer an explanation as to
the supposes deep bruising on Annie's
body that led to different Undertaker's
in two different countries to question
the 30-year olds death without access to
all the pathological evidence in
particular the post-mortem photographs
dr. Hamilton can't make a true
assessment
in the case for suicide that leaves a
big gap there are some cases where it's
like listening to the radio in a
slightly dodgy signal area and instead
of getting a clear signal you've just
got a little bit of hissing the
background it's one or two things and
things that don't add up things that
aren't quite just clear and they will
produce enough just to really muddy the
signal when we set out to produce this
episode we found ourselves weighing what
we were being told against the reality
of what was supposed to happen on that
Saturday in 2005 this lady was in
Prestwick primarily to catch a plane
back to Sweden but somewhere along the
way ended up being discovered on a beach
annie was supposed to get on a plane at
Prestwick Airport and fly to meet her
friend Maria in Sweden everything
appeared on course for that to happen
instead something went wrong at the
airport and she ended up hurrying into
preswick town without ever buying a
ticket either she was running from
something or some unknown trauma not
even her family have any awareness of
cost her to behave erratically whatever
it was after 4:00 p.m. that afternoon
Annie was never seen alive again
[Music]
we've raised lots of questions in this
episode and we're now almost at the end
join us for our final episode where we
will try and bring the story to a
conclusion we should say at this point
if you're one of unease friends from
Edinburgh and have information you
believe to be important then please
email us story cast at Sky dot uk'
[Music]